découvrir les activités d'un développeur
web d'un community manager d'un
spécialiste en objets connectés ou en
cyber sécurité
le principe du summer camp tenu méric du
20 au 31 juillet organisé par saint
quentin en yvelines en collaboration
avec pop school et o'clock ces
structures de formation ont préparé
plusieurs ateliers
le format des ateliers va être dépensé
autour d'une progression qui permet de
s'intéresser d'abord de manière large à
différents métiers et ensuite de
restreindre le périmètre progressivement
par exemple sur le développement web
les jaunes vont pour les jeunes vont
pouvoir développer des petits sites
internet et donc découvrir la
programmation découvrir la mise en page
des éléments sur une page web
l'interactivité destiné aux jeunes âgés
de 16 à 25 ans une centaine de personnes
pourra participer aux dix jours
d'initiation en présentiel à la
pépinière d'entreprises promo paul ou à
distance dans les missions locales ou à
la cité des métiers
objectif favoriser les emplois dans le
numérique dans un contexte de crise
économique sur les entreprises de saint
quentin en yvelines qui nous disent
qu'elles ont besoin de ses compétences
là et donc on essaie de mettre en
adéquation la demande d'emploi avec
l'offre d'emploi sur la filière du
numérique nous avons 5 à 6000 emplois
non pourvus sur saint quentin en
yvelines
inscription gratuite et obligatoire en
fonction des places disponibles avant le
16 juillet prochain